here we go again maradona yeah one of
the frequent opponents he's going for
the Kings Indian normally okay yesterday
we had a bionet attack and okay not in
this game in the bygons II tournament I
wanted to do that but he's deviating
with one of those wood lines with 97
let's see it's really not in fashion
this is kind of this kind of setup but
it's usually not that bad it's too
complicated play as well okay um is c5 a
move or is this crazy yeah let's do that
I haven't thought this through it looks
a bit loose but tries to get the center
open I mean this set up with 97 97 and
so on this is situated doesn't look at
that grade I could have maybe taken only
five and played this in a bit simpler
way mmhmm yeah well here Knight takes is
interesting d take C 596 for the
exchange anyway I have to check with the
noid so no reason to to delay that
if he goes Knight d2 e five I might just
have yeah okay well yeah I'm taking
these six and asked him what his move is
a 96 i thought i had this 196 this looks
like a deja vu kind of thing as if i had
this before well okay let's let's take
first thing later that that should be
good right free queen c7 arm i have
queen bee three chicken everything else
feeling I have the check check and then
night back or is there a better move
probably not yeah hmm takes takes
sometimes I really wish I ever at least
decent attacked X so that I can
completely stomp this kind of stuff to
the ground it's simply completely
winning for white but I hope I'm I mean
cans are all kinds of pieces are hanging
but he's playing without the Queen side
and the king is almost check media and
the goner so it really should be really
really good for white let's see how am I
going to do this it can also start with
Bishop g3 m and detect the Queen the
Queen does not have many squares it can
go to be six for example and still the
rook is attacking deform night is six
where's the Queen going
I know 2d6 I take g7 but the night is
not coming back from there this is some
this is a bit of an issue Bishop g3
queen bee six I don't know an IP i can
go not be five maybe that's a solution
queen bee 695 rookie 2 nite c 7 and rook
p8 495 I really don't know what this was
the most the most convincing way
rookie age I was thinking 95 Queen
mousse and then I can take but does not
mean this is not materially sort of
winning in terms of extra material the
hope is that his some pieces that are
all on the back rank are the problem
night f4 is a pin but it is a fork but
can I set this up like Quincy 3 on and
move like that figs Queen Queen g3 to
attack the night and threaten but you
can take dick antique t5 unfortunately
ok let's do it like that if we know
takes d5 i take c 8 with check Queen g8
and Queen B 7 when he cannot develop the
night time morning I didn't think about
that move great just great um so what
now Quinn to see 5 40 seconds
check yeah we really good out of this
unbelievable stuff yeah okay it's still
not not not so great because he has no
coordination but there's the kind of
game where you know that afterwards the
computer shows you how he could have
totally dismantled like I still has bad
piece coordination night on a six and
and so on I have Knight b6 tactics but
only 20 seconds on the clock
you
this got the week back rank he has to
move the rook now rook t1 I think
directly losses okay maybe you can trade
and then not take the night look T 1 and
not then taking the night might still
not lose directly
yeah I have no time no time on the clock
my Gotham come on
yeah of course I'm overstepping the time
when I'm just completely winning but
okay their shyness this this game should
never ever shall go past the opening
stage I only have three seconds it's
totally irrelevant TM cannot cannot
manage that check like four things
aren't I yeah very idiotic game I mean
okay this is let's see how how how I
could win this this is of course a
complete 195 was already already killing
him Luke see one and wins the Queen the
first one Jack okay some this one but I
mean this this should be excellent as
well I mean I cannot believe that this
is in any way working blacks full of
holes I'm not even material down I mean
no way ever is this going to go into
work I ok this is the win I have to do
this first okay moves him and that's it
yeah that's very simple so what I did is
not this is not working yeah because
really those three pieces are hanging
amazing that's amazing I mean black is
just full of weaknesses he has to look
out of play the bishop out of play and
he always has problems with the back
rain gear and I have no tactic here that
sets that's really close close to
impossible but it is the case yeah I had
the problem was that i made a quick move
here I went here and this took that I
took a moment it took a moment for that
but this I didn't consider and I should
have considered
is simple the Queen has to move he has
to recapture here has to go here and
Jack psych and basically resign sir it's
it's an exchange and still he's got all
pieces are crap so and here it wasn't it
wasn't doing all of us all of a sudden
this is this is holding I mean even this
looks very shaky with the pieces on the
back room and so on yeah but this is no
win f5 this is solves it together Jack
turn jack yeah the way it went it wasn't
even wasn't even that clear took here
Bishop defies the only move but it's
enough yeah okay and then he blunders
into into a loss again but it was clear
that i was losing on time so he probably
didn't pay much attention but of course
the opening was completely unplayable
for like should have should have played
one of one of the winds yeah okay thanks
for watching